في شارع الستين في منطقه في شارع الستين
في الخرطوم لا توجد اي محل تجاريه تعمل
حتى الان فقط المواطنين الذين ياتون
دوله للمدارس في كامل العاصمه هل هناك
دوام رسمي هل يذهب الطلاب الى المدارس هل
الموظفون الى مؤسساتهم جدا جدا
اقفل الكاميرا خلاص اذا مشاهدينا نتابع
الان دوريه
لربما احد المكونين تطالب مراسل العربيه
من الخرطوم سالم الهاشمي باطفاء الكاميرا
اذا
عادي عادي
اذا لا ادري احدى الدوريات الان يتحدثون
مع مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي لا ندري
لاي جهه تتبع هذه الدوريه الان تغادر
سالم انت معي تسمعني احنا بس شغالين لا لا
اشتغلوا احنا انت عارف احنا شغالين بس ما
عندنا حاجه والله
سالم تسمعني
اذا مشاهدين نتابع معكم هذه الدوريه التي
استوقفت
العربيه
وسالته عما يقوم بانه يقوم بالضغط الاحداث
سالم ماذا يدل ان احنا كل ما نتحرك في
الشارع ده ممكن يكون فيها نعم خلاص
نعم نعم اسمعك الان انا بخير الحمد لله
وهي قوه تتبع لقوات الدعم السريع جاءت في
هذه المنطقه وهم الان يطلبون للحديث نعم
تدوم علينا
اذا مشاهدينا الان نتابع
ربما اليه من قوات الدعم السريع تتحدث
العربيه سالم الهاشمي وربما نعم تستفسر
منه عن طبيعه ما يقوم به وربما الجهه التي
يتحدث معها سالم ماذا دار بينكم
نعم هم يستوثقون عن نقل الاحداث وقالوا
انهم يبحثون يجب ان ننقل ما هو على الارض
وان لا نزور الحقائق هذه هي العبارات التي
ذكرتها هذه القوه الان كانت قوه من
سيارتين تتبع للدعم السريع بالفعل لكن لم
يتعرضوا لنا نحن الحمد لله بخير وحتى
الفريق الموجود معي الحمد لله كلهم بخير
الان القوه تحركت مباشره وقدموا اعتذارا
لنا عن هذه المقاطعه جيد الحمد لله نتمنى
لكم السلامه ونرجو ان تعملوا في ظروف امنه
شكرا جزيلا على وجودك معنا سالم الهاشمي
مراسل العربيه كنت معنا من الخرطوم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات